when that whole thing went down with
Will Smith and Chris Rock has that
affected you at all in terms of going to
a club do you think like oh is this
opening up the door for people to jump
on stage and start mixing it up if they
don't like something or if you just put
it out of your mind and said I'm just
not gonna [ __ ] deal with it yeah I
can't I try not to think of it you know
and I try not to think about it on stage
because it just makes for an attention
that's not exactly fun you know what I
mean it's to me comedies like sex it's
like the try not to think of the horrors
you know like you know it kind of ruins
the mood uh when you but uh yeah it was
a weird a weird thing I felt like we we
lost a hero that day yeah yeah how did
you feel did you was you I called Chris
uh I didn't speak with him I left him a
message saying what kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] is this yeah I was outraged
that no one in that audience took this
guy and threw him right the [ __ ] out and
then they're applauding them 10 minutes
late later and I I said this is the most
bizarre thing I've ever seen you know
the worst part too yeah was that they've
they've made them still give out the
award yeah yeah they didn't like dump
out to black or anything like what if
that was like Tilda Swinton that would
have been it would have been a 40-minute
commercial break until they figured out
what happened they just still made him
read the [ __ ] prompter after that and
the thing that hurt me is I know how
hard Chris worked in his career yeah you
know when he got off SNL no one was
thinking about him he was like kind of
dead in the water and this guy Rose from
the grave and made himself into one of
the best stand-up comics Mount Rushmore
for sure bring the pain probably pound
for pound was the most impactful special
of my like Consciousness you know I mean
other than raw or whatever but like I
remember when bring the pain came out it
was like Earth it was it was it changed
everything you know what I mean it was
it was definitely a needle drop you bet
I mean my God he's he's terrific and I
went you know that slap I don't know
what the outcome is but now
unfortunately Chris has got to deal with
that every time he goes on stage he's
the guy who got slapped and he's got to
figure out how to win the audience over
get them to forget about that and all
that kind of [ __ ] I'm so glad you said
that because one of the things that
annoyed me was you know when it was
happening people were like oh and now
he's selling tickets he's like yeah he
had a polished act that he wanted to
present to people and now his people are
buying tickets to hear him talk about
this dumb [ __ ] that he has zero interest
in even bringing up and I think for a
long time that's probably why he didn't
bring it up because he wanted to just
get the story over with he had an act he
was prepared for something else and now
he's he's just hijacked his show it was
like yeah it annoyed the hell out of me
but you know whatever have you spoken
with him or have you just I have I I
haven't spoken to him about that as much
because I'm always you know it's Chris
Rock so I'm always still going to ask
nerdy-ass questions about other [ __ ]
right and he's usually he's usually
giving me career advice and stuff right
so you haven't talked specifically about
that no no no no but but when you talk
to a guy like that are you hesitant to
bring up stuff about stand up no I like
talking about comedy because he's like
some like I don't have a I'm not from a
Showbiz family like no it's kind of good
for me to be able to talk to people like
in a way that I would talk to my big
brothers or my dad or something like
that like if I
like if I call my dad was like Hey you
know should I leave Sno this is what
they're paying me he's gonna be like you
better stay forever you know Chris Rock
is so crazy they give you what you know
like an office you know so right it's uh
it's hard to you know to talk to other
people that I respected that way and in
a relatable way and get relatable advice
but for Chris and for Dave and you know
even you know a tell and you know
certain guys that I look up to I could
kind of talk to them and and actually
get something useful
foreign